just like the Jersey Shore we're fist
bumping
and that's not even the craziest thing
that happened in LA
Fayette
[Music]
welcome to the shotgun wedding red
carpet Premiere there's no biggest star
in the in the world than JLo opting out
of a zipline arrival JLo Graces the red
carpet you look so much better than the
rest of us it's so much more fun when
it's like funny action
spray him in the eyes
it was actually a great experience
because I've never done I've done a lot
of romantic comedies who's kidding who
here you think you would have taken a
second look at me if you knew I was the
maid but I've never done it a romantic
action comedy and just hours before the
premiere Jennifer pays a visit to Jimmy
Kimmel 20 years ago we were supposed to
get married I'd heard I've read that I
think
I think she all fell apart back then and
this time it was like we still had a
life ABS absolutely that had a little
PTSD and then Viva Las Vegas came alive
the wedding was so stressful and one day
Ben just says
okay let's just go to Vegas and get
married tonight
[Music]
JLo's X in the film Lenny Kravitz
oops you forgot to put his shirt all the
way up I'm athletic but I've never done
stunts I've worked on films like the
Batman and you know James Bond so it was
it was serious so they asked if I'd be
willing to do certain things and I said
of course
[Music]
is that genetics or is it like Pilates
and putting her skills to test in the
movie I have to say it was very exciting
they told me to go nuts
nobody with my family
[Music]